يعني هو الرعب الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك عم
تقصف يعني رعب كان فظيع يا محمد معانا
يعني رعب نفسي وجسدي
والله كنا بالسودان بالعاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطوم نفسها وكان فيه يعني نسمع اصوات
تقريبا كذا واخر فتره لما قلنا انه خلص
بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي جدا يعني
منظم ما شاء الله وكان كذا في جنود وكلهم
قاعدين يعطونا ترتيبات يعني فكان الموضوع
جدا سهل الحمد لله وصلتوا مع السفاره
السعوديه هنا
تواصلوا معاهم قالوا هم قالوا لهم نروح
على الميناء البري البحري لمتابعتي المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات